it's
rolling who's most likely to be rolling
hola it's Geneva caras Latina I'm Maya
Iman leage and I'm known as the queen of
flips hi my name is Hersh Lor J from the
legendary House of J hi I'm
mami I'm Don the Ethereal elf goddess of
Brooklyn hi I'm q and I uh am better
than these
[__] hi I'm plasma and I have the
legal documents that prove
otherwise with plain Jane my name is
morphine love Dion hi I'm Mirage amuro
hello it's me a mandatory meeting hello
it's n wind you're it's tsunami Muse hey
y'all it's me sair Cal and we are the
cast of RuPaul's Drag Race season 16 and
we're here to play who's who with Buzz
be
oh my God I say away I'm gonna say away
wait who do you think it is
zunami you know
why
know you know what you know
what if you don't believe it too
much the they just love my accent they
just can't resist it that's all it
is uh a mandatory meeting a mandatory
meeting I'm I'm pretty late usually too
you're late you're late on your makeup
Amanda's late on her
outfit listen it's not that I didn't
finish my makeup it's just if I have the
time I'm going to take it okay that's
real okay that's real and if you don't
have the time you're still going to take
it I don't think there's anyone who I
don't think maybe the other group this
[__] right
two faces complely two faces and they're
both blue I would like to be excluded
from this
narrative tell us how she
feels there's so many you know what all
of them yeah definitely miss alphabet
she very roted roted she's very roted
girl you're
spoil boil milk take the trash out R Fly
Away Little
Bird he not even going to deny that we
all just pointed at her I'll Point
myself that's how I show my love I read
people no you you walk into the room and
you say hi good morning she's said you
look
awful it's not true like fashion fashion
fashion no you didn't do the laugh she
goes I'm better than
you that's it let's keep it
[Applause]
cute I say sair s I am the oldest girl
in the season so I do get a lot of older
references
I was going to say who's the old gay
it's
plasma I'd like the record to note that
I am the youngest person in the cast of
R Dr season 16 but how old is she she is
too old to be serving in the United
States Congress she just
had oh well actually actually down she
said right right touch the skin said hot
mess and I said
I'm oh hot
mess H mess if it's a hot mess Miss Maya
sold her
garments if you were selling it for like
cents
sairs why she look mad about it cuz it's
just other words for being
old
coup you know what it was also we knew
each other from before she's a dumb
[__] and I'm a dumb [__] too so I feel
like that just dumb and dumb dumb and
dum hone Tweedle D and Tweedle dumb one
thing too I'm going to give it to Don
and Amanda I was going to say John and
Amanda the two goblins who are the
characters in um Hades and his little
pain and panic yeah that's me and Amanda
from Hercules
yeah I think we all St we all I think we
all no I didn't get anything that's
everybody yeah everybody that's you it's
just
you it's
everybody everybody named
Mirage I'm I'm not everybody I'm
everything I see how you get that
confused I can see how you can do that
marage you're the type of girl you walk
into a place you walk out you're wearing
everything that's
there uh we're not Petty like that I
I would give that to nymphia I think oh
cuz she would look up and down and be
like I'm very anal I would
definitely very
millimeter but he
secret yeah honestly I will say though
these two are the girls yes also out of
the girls these will they'll put us
together to lipsic against each
other
may I think Maya or may but I also feel
like I could come back you could you
should I could and I
[Music]
am Morphine Morphine boots will you do
it though yeah who would you not want to
paint who who has a hard canvas to paint
oh oh my God that's so
shady an evil C it's half the
cast we want names it's the other
house you know I like to call it Brick
City honey
a no I want to paint Don's face and I
want Don to paint my face that would be
a that would be I want to see I want to
make her into a full-blown Latina o
[Music]
donat
Maya
Maya I was going to say Maya baby Maya
no Maya made me laugh a lot there's one
particular moment in the show not too
much on Miss mother R now but she
probably had to change her garment from
under the desk she was pissing [__]
throwing up laughing Hy a laugh like
crazy I I will too muchad I will say
that when R was laughing at her though I
don't know if it was intentional on
[Applause]
my really no more questions no more
questions we're just about to get
started started is it our turn to ask
you guys questions we get
it bye thank you
bu than
you we love you and remember to watch
Rupa Drag Race season 16 every
Friday at
[Music]
a